it works we have done many studies levy
works but several things number one you
must have the right protective equipment
the right mass now this is the right
mass you see yes a blue color on the
outside because it's what the proof then
you have white on the inside which is
solvent yeah
sorry if I cough it absorbs it now so
you gotta wait like this the blue on the
outside the white on the inside you have
seen people wearing it like this mmm
totally wrong you see you see people
have very much it's only one piece of
paper
those are not for infection control you
can see this year this type little thick
band here is to show you that you should
put it on the top yeah why because once
you wear it then you squeeze it so they
let just you gotta pinch the nose yeah
these are nose and then you put it down
very important because you don't need to
fall like this and you see someone do
you'd say hey please you gotta cover
your nose have you seen doctors doing
this you know talking to you yeah yeah
this wrong the removal is just as
important you gotta listen to this
because once you wear a mask you should
consider it dirty then when you remove
you don't touch it didn't move in such
that oh heavens are you removing such
that it touches also soil you're
removing don't touch it and drop it
yeah and then do hand hygiene yeah
you